[Music]
okay well welcome everybody my name is
Vitaly namer
and I am the Grand Master resident here
at the same - is chess club I'm going to
be here from beginning of this week
until the end of March so for the whole
month of March so I'm very excited to be
here it's my second time being the head
coach of the Chess Club I don't know if
you guys knew but st. Louis is actually
considered the capital of chess in the
world
not only in the US but even in the world
some of the most popular chess players
come to compete here pretty much all the
world champions like Magnus Carlsen
Vishy Anand
kramnik as well as Garry Kasparov just
came out of retirement ik his first
chess tournament was here in this chess
club so yeah so this is kind of like the
the shrine of chess but for chess people
anyway so what are we going to do today
so today we are going to continue on the
same topic as was our first lesson today
so the first lesson I was introducing
the opening which is called the dragon
okay so the dragon and the Sicilian
dragon is one of the most sharpest a
chess openings of all times lots of
sacrifices lots of combinations lots of
calculations forks pins mates stalemates
so lots and lots of exciting stuff going
on over there obviously there's lots of
theory involved if you do want to take
the dragon into the next level but yeah
so today on our second part today for
the advanced class I wanted to show you
how a few games in the dragon and how to
play the dragon with the black color in
this game
Judy Pogo was was playing white versus
versus magnus carlsen so let's see let's
see what happens so II for and as I said
we're going to start with this Sicilian
dragon c5 Knight f3 pawn to d6 this is
our main line pawn to d4 pawn takes on
d4 Knight takes on d4 Knight f6
attacking the pawn on e4 Knight c3
usually people who play the dragon they
know those those moves by heart so this
is move number five and you know so you
usually up until move number ten if you
are considering professional just being
a professional chess player professional
chess players know up until move number
1520 sometimes even 30 so you can kind
of blitz out those those moves in a
theory not to waste any time so 93 g6
with fianchetto or Bishop Bishop e3
Bishop g7 f3 preventing Knight g4 this
is what we discussed today you know
previous class and 96 black and
technically castle before playing 96 but
they are both considered as good good
moves Queen d2 Castle Bishop c4 Bishop
d7 and long castles so as you know one
of the main weapons that white has
against the dragon is called the
Yugoslav attack and this is when white
is starting to create some pawn
advancement on their a King side and so
basically why does going try to advance
all his pawns on the King side to expose
blacks King and black is going to try to
push on the other side so let's see what
happens so castle and rook 2
see eight now as we said in our prior
lesson today if white tries to for
example play g4 or h4 and basically
ignore blacks threat black can play here
the strong move Knight takes on default
so this is the combination that we saw
now part once and Queen takes before 90
is G for attacking the Queen and
basically this combination winter piece
that's a good question and if it takes
to the bishop then we can just take the
bishop on c4 so this is why this is why
they try to take out the Queen because
the Queen is kind of defending the
bishop well you know obviously I do D
polio the strongest women on the planet
I did not fell for it and she played
this move Bishop to b3 so this is the
idea to treat the bishop from the attack
of of the d-roc okay what do we do next
so black to move what is the idea here
with black
yes please
so black to move a six okay so yes
that's a good that's a good preparation
of right because you have some ideas of
playing b5 right so that's the plan
and now the problem a six is it's
probably going to be too slow in those
kind of positions and those kind of
openings like the dragon it's a race we
have to attack as fast as possible okay
there is no time to waste anymore for
example white immediately going to play
g4 then be fived and h4 and usually just
going to be too slow for us for black so
good good plan but is another maneuver
that black can do and the maneuver is is
that black is trying to get this Bishop
on v3 because this Bishop is very very
very strong on this diagonal so how do
we do this how do we get this Bishop on
b3 yes please
okay so night 95 very good now this is
probably also going to work however I
don't really like to put the night my
nights on the edge of the board actually
I don't like to put any pizza on the
edge of the board
unless it's a king for example and I can
put it on h8 but let's try to find a
better square for this night more
central square yes yes so Knight to e5
very good so this is the manoeuvre
basically we can focus on this outpost
on c4 and this is where the knight is
going to so this is what was played in
the game so Knight to e5 and now white
played the g4 white starts his attack on
the Kings side now it usually black
immediately plays this move Knight seif
94 but now black decided to unleash his
pawns and as we say this is the Tail of
the Dragon so to attack with the tail so
if they'd immediately be 5 now at first
it looks like we're just losing a pawn
right because Knight takes bishop takes
and the other night is not take on d5
but that's not so true we're actually
not losing opponent why is that why
don't we do the pawn yes very good very
good so if this Knight Dixon on b5 for
example Bishop takes takes then now we
can take on f3 ok always ask yourselves
in your games what has changed in the
position you know so this knight on d4
was defending the f3 pawn he is no
longer there and so this allows us to to
take a left 3 now when the f3 pawn falls
then the g4 pawn falls as well and the
e4 pawn falls as well probably in the
next few moves and obviously we are
attacking the Queen
so not so good for why to take the bait
and take on b5 so obviously I do deep
sodas in the game and she decided to
play g5 attacking attacking the night
why do you think that the world champion
Hill did black to move black to move yes
okay somewhere so you saying just to
move the night okay that's one option
maybe Knight h5 right maybe night back
back to e eight kind of more of a
defensive solution but remember with a
dragon we always attack always push
forward how can we counter-attack in
this position yes before yes
counter punch nice look at this although
all the Knights are attacked actually
all of the Knights are aligned on this
diagonal it's pretty funny
exactly okay so before now if white
would have taken this night we would
take this night and if it takes the
bishop we can take a screen now if we
would a check that is correct now if it
takes the pawn well we can take the pawn
of six and look at this now we destroy
White's castle right so why decided not
to go for this so I decided white what
we say likely that look like we like to
say it blinked first and Judas went back
with a knight Knight c2e2 okay so now we
have to move the knight the night went
to to h5 okay so why to play how do you
think white continue this attack
yes that is correct
okay it can public she can tamale take
the pond I didn't know why she didn't
take this this poem before but I assume
maybe there was some kind of a problem
here
what about maybe a five and then my next
book is gonna be a four maybe I can
somehow harass this Bishop on b3 now
this this point we call this a
positional sacrifice remember I said it
in the dragon the goal is to give away
our dose of those two points for those
two points to expose the position so
sometimes for black this is going to be
good to give up the his pawns because
it's going to open up the files is we
call this a positional sacrifice
so why decide not take the pawn but to
play it different move anybody else
yeah corner for right damn okay attack
on the Kings side so attacking all night
the night went to sea for for King the
Queen and the bishop bishop takes and
rook takes so this is the one of the
most popular maneuvers that we see in a
dragon exchanging one of our nights for
the bishop okay so now why plate b3 why
I decided okay this this rookin c4 is
just too annoying I have to kick it out
so b3 rook went back to c7 and now okay
how do you continue here with white we
can either play f5 or really most of
most of the time white is trying to open
up this h-file
but how do we do it that is a really
good question yes very good 93 okay so
the idea is that if black takes the
night for example pon takes and maybe
somehow to swing the Queen on h2 and
checkmate on h7 pretty clever huh pretty
clever
so nigt was played but the deficiency of
this move Knight GT is that is law no
longer defending the city square so
Magnus saw that and immediately put the
broken c3 so Rock City was played Knight
xh5 pawn takes on h5 and white that came
to be one that came to be one is a very
popular move to be done in the for white
in the dragon in the Yugoslav attack why
is that well because usually because
usually black puts his Queen on a5 and
tries to attack the a to pawn so now
what is using what we call prophylaxis
anybody knows what the mean everybody
anybody heard about this term in chess
prophylaxis buff is something anybody
knows what it means yes
right so and then you prevent it very
good so prophylaxis and chances that you
need to think about what is my opponents
plan not my plan what is he going to do
and how can I prevent this okay so my so
Weiss is seeing that black wants to play
Queen a5 and attack his pollinate too so
he plead offending the pond even before
it would got attacked so keen to be won
and Queen to a5 okay f5 look at this the
pawns are coming the pawns are coming
okay black the move what would you do
with black how do we continue our attack
with black we need to bring more pieces
more pieces to the attack yes
to h6 okay interesting politics what do
you guys think about this move good
that's good right it's probably gonna
expose the king because well first of
all it's exposing it but then I'm also
going to lose my time now as a rule of
thumb
just remember usually you do not want to
move your pawns form the King in front
of the King because you are going to
expose right it's pretty much like think
about a new house you want to take off
the roof I don't know I mean if it's
sunny it can be nice right right like a
like a Sun roof or something but if it's
raining and then it's snowing not such a
good idea so you want to keep him safe
okay yes question right the window okay
so anybody else black to move here how
do we continue the attack of the dragon
look at this fire over here this Bishop
is right here attacking the the rook is
in there
the Queen is activated who is not in the
game who is sleeping who is sleeping
somebody did not wake up in the morning
forgot to wake up there's a piece that
is sleeping somebody who I haven't
healed before yes please yeah
correct so where would you put the rope
okay so me my PO take the bishop now
usually we want to put the rooks on open
files which file is the most open the
most open yes very good rook F to c8
perfect so this is what we call in chess
a battery when we align two rooks
or a rook and a queen on the same file
or maybe sometimes on the same diagonal
if it's a rook if it's a queen and a
bishop we call this a battery it's much
much more powerful and we always pay
play powerful chest right alrighty so
rook to c8 was played in a game now
black a black play white played f6 BAM
he's trying to shut down our our fire
now what do we do do we take one of six
do we escape with a bishop what to do
raise your hand
yes
take on c2 okay interesting
anybody else yes you will just snap the
pond okay
yes sir we'll be proud the grab the pond
yes anybody else now if we take first of
all if we take on c2 then Knight
excellency - so that's probably not
going to work if we take the pawn that's
exactly what white wants to do it one is
not take take and now root 2 gee 100
Nora follow our heads right so we're
gonna be very very exposed very
dangerous so magnus carlsen the world
champion finds a counter-attack how can
we counter-attack and keep the G file
closed yes please in the back very good
'if I've ignore the threat and that's
exactly what happened exactly so now if
they take the pawn sometimes so this is
that did not happen in the game right
now but sometimes this point is actually
going to be good for us as black because
this is gonna count as a defender for
black yeah it's a bit strange
so why played Knight f5 moving his
Knight Bishop takes a 5 he takes a 5 and
now black to move let's see if you can
find a way how to expose the white king
how do we get to him it looks like our
fire has been put out but what to do we
have so many pieces next to the King so
now we are going to look for those
sacrifices right yes
very good real take see - Quinn take see
2 root X E - King take c2 and Queen
takes a - check
and now the hunt for the King begins
downtown um okay so night Queen taxi -
clintus a -
king 2 D 3 now a Magnus decided no okay
this one is gonna fall anyway so he just
moved the bishop to f8 Roxy one and now
d5 BAM he even uses those two pawns
so pawn to d5 rook H 2 D 1 was played
Queen to be - wasn't what's the threat
of this move Queen to be - was a threat
who knows
yes who knows yes
not exactly
Adi yeah II for very good there's a
checkpoint in one move coming right
because the Queen is controlling all of
those squares so it just looks like a
very polite move this is just a very
quiet move Queen B - but this this was a
nice idea Queen B - so Bishop d2 was
played check King e - and now II for
Bishop III Queen B - checked so how do
we how many how many passed pawns Black
has in this position how many probably
passed pawns do we have in this position
yes four one two three four and now
black gets another passport damn its
Queen and the five passed pawns or maybe
this is not exactly a platform because
still this this this pawn is guarding
him against two rooks well the Queen is
just too powerful let's see how the game
ended rule takes d5 and now Queen to b8
now the idea of Queen debate is first of
all to defend the back rank because we
sometimes we need to be aware of back
rank mates and also to support the push
of the pawn the b-pawn so queen beatrix
C - D 1 B 3 root D 8 Queen before check
King of to be - we're almost there we're
almost there
rugby 1 what is trying to block 8 the
pawn but now we're we play Queen a5
attacking the rook and the pawn on f5 so
Queen a5 r ok 8 takes
kingi one check King F - Queen - c7
another one of those tricky moves what's
the idea of 27 who knows hook who can
see the threat of Queen c7 yes Queen to
c2 check yes fork and what if what if
the rook takes on B to go into H - very
good a nice skewer is what we call the
skewer so Queen to c7 rook had to move
the d1 check King to e1 and now how do
we win this what's the easiest win to
win this position yes Queen c2 and
what's the idea is to promote right but
then rook b8 to play Queen c2 or play
rugby 8 and stop stop the pond okay
that's a good idea but not working
there's an easier way how to win this
yes Queen GT check and ke to be enough
take in d2 trying to chase the King
there's an easier way yes the bishop is
pinned guys is pinned it's just a fan in
the King wow how do we win this easy way
how do we promote this guys is is not
allowing us we need to get rid of this
guy yes yes Queen - h1 check very good
Cain de - and then BAM Queen takes d1
and this is where the Judit Polgar
resigned because of King takes well me
make another Queen and Queen versus a
rock that's an easy win
well Queen and we have three past pawns
so relatively easy easy win so thank you
for listening guys this was the dragon
don't forget if you have any other
questions and the end of the lesson you
can take some puzzles over over here you
have any questions my card is over there
and don't forget always play powerful
chess
[Music]
you
[Music]